buddy all right normally you wouldn't
say coffee is good for babies but in
this case it is your cup of coffee can
help children in nevada to explain that
we have ron winnicora of founders coffee
and kelly maxwell from babies bounty
thank you both for being here thanks for
having us let's talk about founders
coffee because you guys are always doing
this you're you're hooking up with
non-profits and helping them out with
different beverages right yes we call it
our drink of the month or our giving
drink and so every month we pick a new
charity a local charity to partner with
and then we come up with a new drink
concoction every month so it's kind of
our way of switching it up a little bit
giving back to the community and making
it fun so a dollar from every drink i
love it okay we're going to talk about
this month's drink in just a second but
kelly let's talk about babies bounty you
guys have been around for what 14 years
or so we have uh we've been in operation
14 years working to improve health
outcomes for families living in poverty
two years ago we launched our diaper
bank program as a result of covid we
have since distributed uh nearly 2
million diapers to uh almost 27 000
southern nevadans that is fantastic and
it really is serving a need and
especially during covid you guys were
needed yes initially this was launched
because folks were hoarding diapers the
way they were hoarding toilet paper
but as
that immediate need waned we realized
that there was an overwhelming need for
diaper resources here in southern nevada
i believe we're now the only consistent
diaper resource
in the state
so now bronwyn uh you have a certain cup
of coffee where a dollar will be donated
to baby's bounty so what is it this
month a dollar to a baby's bounty is the
ice cream dream it's like a neapolitan
inspired ice cream so strawberry
chocolate vanilla
because we can make one absolutely let's
make it less
awesome
so you're going to pour i'm going to
give you that okay
we've made coffee before yes
i'm not a barista that's okay i i made
it cold okay okay so you just tell me
what to do strawberry syrup okay pour it
on in there got it that's going to be
our strawberry flavor and then you want
to do milk you can have a little more
than halfway okay yep and tell people
you have two locations we do st rose
parkway across the street from costco
which we're doing an event there this
weekend and then our other location is
on sunset and durango terrific okay now
the rest of the coffee the coffee this
is sweetened condensed milk infused
espresso
and then
chocolate whipped cream oh nice nice
touch
this is some coffee in there so this is
the messy part
but house made chocolate whipped cream
right on top so you have strawberry
vanilla and chocolate oh you're true
neopolitan
that's awesome you did it that was a
good looking drink too so that goes on
for the month of yeah one week left oh
this particular one so hurry on in and
you get to help babies bounty what else
do you guys have it coming up well so on
saturday uh from 8 to 12 we are asking
folks not only to come and and buy the
coffee drinks but also to bring diapers
wipes and toiletry items infant toiletry
items to founders coffee in henderson uh
we're basically filling our mobile
diaper bank with diapers and wipes so
that's the saint rose location right
yeah 35 12 st okay and again the time is
8 to 12 this saturday morning all right
so come by fill the van with diapers and
wipes and have a great cup of coffee as
well
thank you both very much for being here
all right you can help baby's bounty to
fill the van again that saturday at
founders coffee in henderson goes from 8
until noon